hay buenas noticias sobre la salud de un
verdadero campeón estamos hablando del
ciclista colombiano invernal sin raúl tú
que me has preguntado en los días
previos cómo avanzaba de can como estaba
ganando noticias buenísimas después de
dos semanas de hospitalización egan
recibió el alta médica y comenzó su
proceso de rehabilitación así lo
comunicó la clínica de la universidad de
la sabana al norte de bogotá en donde el
corredor de líneas winner years ha sido
sometido a varias cirugías después de
haber chocado contra la parte trasera de
un bus mientras entrenaba a las afueras
de la capital colombiana el campeón del
tour de francia en 2019 y vigente
ganador del giro de italia dijo que
recibió una segunda oportunidad
escuchamos que dijo
el siguiente del mundo estaba pensando
por día y lo que hace
le habrá coincidido todo para dar con
buenos profesionales porque
de nuestro por ustedes
el punto sería ligeramente así que debo
darles gracias por permitirme tener una
segunda oportunidad fracturas y no sé
costillas fracturas en dos vértebras en
la mano a la mandíbula el fémur
prácticamente destrozado y lo vemos ahí
también lo vimos de pie es tremendo ese
muchacho seguramente volverá claro que
si juan toda la mejor energía para la
buena salud y la pronta recuperación del
campeón en bernal